[Applause]
[Music]
no one cared about the world health
organization until coronavirus arrived
and of course it takes a pandemic for
the world to start looking at what the
World Health Organization says and does
it's our international reference in
everything as it has to do with medicine
[Music]
politicians may have ideological biases
but the w-h-o is made up of scientists
in other words their decisions should
not be motivated by political battles
but by strict compliance with the
scientific method right well Pat a major
step for traditional Chinese medicine
going global
traditional medicine originating from
traditional Chinese medicine TCM has
been incorporated into the 11th revision
of the International classification of
diseases ICD marking a major step 40 CMS
internationalization Jean Juan nets and
you'll say well I mean why is this news
so important well you see the
International classification of diseases
is the document where the w-h-o outlines
the procedures for diagnosing diseases
and the treatments that exist to
alleviate them its contents influences
the policies of governments and
insurance companies around the world in
other words entering this classification
means the difference between remaining a
pseudoscience or being covered by
private insurance or even receiving
public funding from the health systems
of numerous countries
and you're probably thinking so what
does all of this have to do with
politics but I think you can probably
already guess the answer the influence
of China and increasingly remarkable
influence by now many of you have
already heard about the w-h-o scandal
regarding Taiwan basically the w-h-o
does not recognize Taiwan as a member
states they consider it just as one more
Chinese region
[Music]
this is a problem for each country that
is fighting the coronavirus and this is
because Taiwan is one of the countries
that is best containing the pandemic
their example is vital for other
countries wanting to take effective
action thus China is doing everything it
can to prevent it but we're not going to
talk about that today I know what some
of you might be thinking uh already the
visual politic guys have sold out to the
United States and a criticizing China
indiscriminately it's terrible who's
paying them Trump really look if you
take a look at our playlist you'll see
that we have over 40 videos about China
and just as many about the United States
you can find tons of videos where we've
criticized Donald Trump and US politics
on plenty of fronts and we've never had
the slightest problem highlighting the
positive aspects of China of which there
are many for example their investments
in Africa many things from the one belt
one road project and of course the huge
growth they've had in the last 30 years
but there are many areas where such
influence by china can be very dangerous
and this is one of them think about it
criticizing a politician is to be
expected however the w-h-o is a
scientific Authority we have no choice
but to trust what they tell us because
we aren't medical experts
moreover in the fight against fake news
the w-h-o is an objective voice and that
referee cannot have ideological or
religious agendas only one thing can be
based on fact scientific method so the
question we are asking ourselves today
is why has the w-h-o accepted
traditional Chinese medicine does that
mean it works does that mean its
scientific is there a political issue
behind this recognition Confucius said I
do not seek to know the questions I only
try to know the answers so a visual
politic today we're going to answer
these questions but first the history
[Music]
the planet's doctor Confucius said study
the past if you want to predict the
future that's why we have to travel back
to 1948 when the w-h-o was created in
Geneva Switzerland and some of you will
be wondering but Simon why is a UN
specialized Health Agency even needed
and I think that's already been made
pretty clear during this pandemic
diseases do not respect borders we're
all interested in the rest of the world
being healthy but hold on a minute
because its role is not only limited to
the coronavirus for example the work
they have completed to expand
vaccination campaigns is also very
important
and know this is not just a matter of
humanitarian aid for example imagine
someone who lives in the Congo the Congo
is a very poor country and most people
can't go to the doctor let's assume that
suddenly there was a measles outbreak in
the Congo well it would only take one
Congolese to arrive in Spain Germany or
the United States to unleash a measles
epidemic in our own backyard and the
truth is that the whu-oh has a lot to be
proud of
[Music]
its greatest success came 40 years ago
smallpox smallpox is the only human
disease that today exists only in
laboratories in addition other ailments
are also practically under control so
diseases like polio and no longer a
problem although they could be again if
countries like Afghanistan or Pakistan
do not finish eradicating it for this
the w-h-o serves three functions as a
global doctor the first is to support
developing countries dhoop extends their
vaccination campaigns
I commend the brave polio vaccine
workers mostly women working to stamp
out polio in Pakistan important gains
have been made but we need a concerted
push to eradicate this awful disease
Antonio Guterres secretary-general of
the UN and in the poorest countries the
w-h-o is directly involved in containing
infectious disease outbreaks
[Music]
w-h-o supports South Sudan in oral
cholera vaccination campaign to prevent
the risk of a cholera outbreak in ranked
the second function is to monitor what
is happening in the field of human
health and make useful recommendations
and sound alarms that all countries
should take into account we've been
seeing this over the last few months WH
o declares coronavirus a global pandemic
and countries react well ok not everyone
reacts the same way and others react
when it's too late the handling of this
crisis by some countries may be
disastrous but the w-h-o declared an
international health emergency on the
30th of January finally there is the
function of updating the VAD Amica that
is to clarify those treatments that work
and those that don't
for example the w-h-o recently declared
beware of nitrosamines they are
potentially carcinogenic so what of each
country's drug agencies done in response
to this warning nitrosamines abounds in
drugs like zantac
FDA finds impurity and popular heartburn
medicine zantac that could cause cancer
CNBC so now you're probably wondering
how does the WHI work well let me
explain the WHI is made up of physicians
of like health specialists scientists
and epidemiologists from all around the
world but they are looking under the
microscope all day the laboratory work
is more than 700 research centers and
universities in some 80 countries
working with the w-h-o on projects what
the w-h-o does is coordinate all of that
information and you'll say well that's
fine but who runs the WHI that's where
the World Health Assembly comes in once
a year all countries meet in Geneva or
and there they make the main decisions
for the organization one of its
functions is to appoint the executive
committee and its director general who
is currently the Ethiopian Ted Ross at
Ham non-abrasive
as you can imagine each country's vote
carries the same weight but watch out
because that was the good news many of
you will already be wondering but all
this is fine but it pays for it when it
comes to paying not all countries are
the same funding the w-h-o depends
mostly on countries such as the United
States the United Kingdom Germany in
Japan in other words for decades the
United States has had an enormous
capacity for influence in voting that
everything has changed with the arrival
of Donald Trump remember America first
some of you might think that this was an
empty slogan but do not be fooled Trump
has always been against international
organizations what is often called
multilateralism and this explains news
stories like this
from seeks to have us funding for World
Health Organization as coronavirus
ragers foreign policy so what can happen
in the international sphere when the
United States takes a step back it
allows China to take a step forward and
take its place so is that a good thing
or a bad thing
well let's take a look right now
[Music]
Confucius said learning without thinking
is useless thinking without learning
dangerous and you know that tradition is
based more on repetition and learning as
we have explains scientific medicine and
traditional medicine coexist in China's
health care system traditional medicine
believes in Qi the vital energy that
circulates through the bodies channels
called meridians health problems are
identified as imbalances in your Chi so
traditional Chinese medicine seeks to
restore that balance through different
herbal remedies and therapies such as
suction cups in acupuncture
at this point something you're probably
thinking else Simon you're so hero
centric what's wrong with you do you
just trust pharmaceutical companies well
wait a minute we're going to talk a
little bit about philosophy and the
scientific method you see science has
nothing to do with pharmaceuticals or
countries the scientific method is based
on two pillars reproducibility and
falsifiability I mean a thing isn't
scientific because a scientist or an
American says it is no science exists if
it meets these premises and I'm going to
explain it to you
with a concrete example the history of
aspirin for centuries
both Egyptians and some tribes in
America prepared willow bark infusions
to alleviate their headaches in 1763 a
scientist named Edward stone conducted
an experiment with 50 patients all of
these patients had a headache he gave
each one of them willow infusions and
checked whether he had relieved the pain
or not
this means it was a false experiment I
mean the result is good or bad based on
objective criteria does your head still
hurt yes or no and this is very
important back to highlights because
many times we find news stories that say
things like study confirms the Tropper
makes you happier sorry but happiness is
not an objective state but the story
doesn't end here
years later other scientists carried out
other similar experiments since they all
got the same results that means it was a
reproducible experiment that is it
doesn't matter if the patients were from
Arkansas or Munich in all cases the
willow bark took away the headache but
not only that after a lot of research
they realized that they could isolate
the active substance from willow bark
and this chemical was acetyl salicylic
acid
finally in 1899 by I found a way to
produce the substance industrially and
safely and that's how aspirin came to be
in other words science doesn't go
against nature moreover there is
knowledge of traditional Chinese
medicine that can be validated by the
scientific method for example to you you
won the Nobel Prize in medicine in 2015
for discovering that artemisinin a
herbal remedy was effective against
malaria in this case we are no longer
talking about traditions but science and
you'll say so where's the problem with
traditional Chinese medicine well most
treatments and not science-based for
example there are people who take ejo
jelly made from boiling donkey skins
they say it treats anemia and prevents
cancer but there's no science behind
that the only argument for defending
this treatment is 4000 years of
tradition but this is not even the worst
example in many cases these treatments
can be dangerous we're not just talking
about animals that spread diseases the
truth is nature itself can be dangerous
consider this study reveals that nearly
90% of traditional Chinese medicines
contain trace amounts of disturbing and
toxic substances business insider and an
awesome you're thinking what about the
multi-million dollar pharmaceutical
business I mean you're probably thinking
all those visual politic guys I was just
serving the interest of capitalism yes
you're right big pharmaceutical
companies make a lot of money but you
know what they're not the only ones
traditional Chinese medicine closes in
on 50 billion dollar market with
long-awaited nod from w-h-o South China
Morning Post because yes this is about
traditional medicine but don't think
about a healer with ancestral knowledge
passed down from generation to
generation after remember that there are
4,000 traditional medicine hospitals in
China do you have to think about whole
factories that make this type of
medicine and yes there are even remedies
that attempts to cure Hirono virus in
Africa amid Cova 19 outbreak Xinhua net
exactly so remember the one belt one
road project that huge infrastructure
network to connect China's of the
world's well check this out
under the radar Africa is becoming
traditional Chinese medicines best
customer global risk insights however up
until now outside of China traditional
medicine has been considered
pseudoscience that is it may be legal
the doctors can't recommend this or
health insurance companies accept it as
a valid treatment I mean it's like if
you want to do yoga good for you enjoy
it the insurance company's not gonna pay
for it you see it's not medicine
so who's the authority that decides what
heals doesn't oh yes that would be the
WHI Chinese influence Confucius said the
man who moves mountains begins by
setting doubles aside and who can that
man be for China yes Ted Ross at Hanan
gay braces the current director general
at the whi WH o proposes partnerships
with China along Silk Road do X in the
phase of the void left by Trump it is
now China that has the capacity to
influence the WHI Beijing is the one
that pulls the strings of the World
Health Assembly to make de dress the new
director general and is this good for
anything well the truth is yes to begin
with the w-h-o does not recognize Taiwan
as an independent state that is
according to them Taiwan is just one
more Chinese region
principal it makes sense Taiwan's
political status is complicated because
of this they don't even have a presence
of the UN the problem now is that Taiwan
has been one of the best examples in the
fight against coronavirus it's very
important to be able to study its
example mostly because it's a very
useful model for everyone however all
w-h-o officials avoid this issue well
considered
taiwan's membership
hello I couldn't hear your question okay
yeah and I'm eating that let me let me
repeat the question let's move to
another one then right like this because
I'm I'm actually curious on talking
about Taiwan as well on Taiwan's keys
but we're not just talking about
coronavirus again the main signs of
China's influence at the wh show this
[Music]
major step for traditional Chinese
medicine going global gene winnette and
what arguments has been proposed to
validate this type of medicine since
poor countries cannot afford the
equipments and treatments required for
scientific medicine they can at least
have traditional medicine I don't know
what this approach would look like but I
think if you don't have scientific
evidence it's not medicine and this
isn't just me several other institutions
say so as well the European academies of
science and medicine call for
evidence-based diagnosis and therapy in
response to the w-h-o inclusion of
traditional Chinese medicine
in its standard framework F II am
however the whou has not jumped on the
brakes the inclusion of traditional
Chinese medicine in the medication guide
will become a reality in 2022 it is not
yet clear what types of therapies and
treatments will be included we still
don't know if we'll find extracts of
gecko lizard bat soup or will it be
limited to her ballroom ADIZ in any case
this w-h-o decision could become a
public health hazard but wait a minute
because giving the green lights to
traditional chinese medicine has a
greater risk in other fields than we
realize as carry-on
and what is traditional Chinese medicine
and what can it treats Forbes notice
that we are talking about a journal as
prestigious as Forbes and in this
article they give complete validity to
the methods of traditional Chinese
medicine imagine what could happen from
now on with a lot of media which as they
begin to trust the WHI begin to
recognize traditional medicine as of
discipline just as valid as the
scientific one
[Music]
[Applause]
for example I don't know about medicine
I can't be checking all of the studies
to see what's good and what's bad
that's what authoritative sources are
for but not only that the problem is
even worse this also affects this
platform YouTube
[Music]
like other platforms YouTube is fighting
fake news I mean consider what happen
with coronavirus if you search
coronavirus on google you get
information from public authorities and
the WHI moreover if you look at the foot
of this video you'll also see several
links to the w8 show and this is all
fantastic thanks to this YouTube has
prevented many people from believing in
such barbarities like drinking bleach or
alcohol to cure the corona virus but
that has a risk
the w8 show is one of those arbitrators
of who decides what's true and what's
not so imagine what could happen if
traditional Chinese medicine is accepted
by the WHI automatically this video
could be considered fake news and in the
meantime the gentleman who might be
recommending Himalayan viagra would be
making large profits
so as Confucius would say seeing the
right way and not doing it is a lack of
courage or principle so now the question
is over to you what role do you think
the w-h-o will play in the post
coronavirus world do you think
traditional Chinese medicine will expand
internationally and rival scientific
medicine leave your answer in the
comments below as well as in this survey
and I really do hope you enjoyed this
video please do hit like if you did do
not forget to subscribe for brand new
videos and as always thank you for
watching if you want to learn more about
politics and world affairs and here's
some more of my lovely voice come check
out the reconsidered podcast where we
don't do the thinking for you find
reconsider @ww re consider mediacom or
on Apple or Google Play or your favorite
podcast
[Music]